electrolytic cells use an electric
current to drive a thermodynamically
unfavorable reaction before we look at a
diagram of an electrolytic cell let's
look at the half reactions that will
occur in the cell
in one half reaction liquid sodium ions
react with an electron to form liquid
sodium metal because the liquid sodium
ion is gaining an electron this
represents the reduction half reaction
the other way to tell that this is a
reduction half reaction is to assign
oxidation numbers liquid sodium ions
have an oxidation number of plus one
and liquid sodium metal has an oxidation
number of zero so going from plus one to
zero is a decrease or a reduction in the
oxidation number therefore liquid sodium
ions are reduced to form liquid sodium
metal in this half reaction
in our next unbalanced half reaction
liquid chloride anions turn into
chlorine gas
if we assign oxidation numbers
liquid chloride anions have a oxidation
number of -1 and chlorine gas has an
oxidation number of zero so going from
-1 to 0 is an increase in the oxidation
number therefore the liquid chloride
anions are oxidized to chlorine gas so
this is the oxidation half reaction and
we need to balance it since we have two
chlorines on the right we need to put a
two as a coefficient in front of the
chloride anions on the left
loss of electrons is oxidation and since
we're oxidizing two chloride anions
we're going to lose two electrons
as a quick reminder one way to remember
that loss of electrons is oxidation and
gain of electrons is reduction is to
think about leo the lion goes ger so
loss of electrons is oxidation and gain
of electrons is reduction
next let's add our two half reactions
together to get the overall redox
reaction and before we do that we have
to make sure the number of electrons are
equal in both half reactions since we
have two electrons in the oxidation half
reaction and only one electron in the
reduction half reaction we need to
multiply everything in our reduction
half reaction through by two so that
would be two liquid sodium ions two
electrons and two liquid sodiums
when we add the two half reactions
together the two electrons cancel out
and we get two liquid sodium cations
plus two liquid chloride anions
goes to two liquid sodiums and chlorine
gas
so if we had some molten sodium chloride
we could form sodium and chlorine gas
however delta g naught for this reaction
is greater than zero which means this
reaction is thermodynamically
unfavorable so in order for this
reaction to occur we need some sort of a
power source to provide an electric
current
to drive this thermodynamically
unfavorable reaction
here's a diagram showing our
electrolytic cell for the electrolysis
of molten sodium chloride and let's
start with the power source so the
negative terminal of the power source is
where the electrons come from so imagine
we have electrons moving in this wire
toward the inert electrode on the right
inert means the electrodes aren't going
to participate in this reaction
for example the electrode could be a
piece of platinum metal which is very
unreactive at the surface of the
electrode the electrons reduce the
liquid sodium ions into liquid sodium
therefore liquid sodium will form at
this electrode
the melting point of sodium chloride is
higher than the melting point of sodium
therefore at this high temperature
sodium will remain a liquid eventually
when the liquid sodium cools down you
would have some solid sodium metal
because reduction is occurring at the
electrode on the right the electrode on
the right must be the cathode next let's
think about the other inert electrode on
the left at this electrode oxidation is
taking place because liquid chloride
anions are turning into chlorine gas
so we would see bubbles of chlorine gas
at this electrode
and as the liquid chloride anions are
oxidized that's loss of electrons so the
electrons would flow through this wire
back toward the positive terminal of the
power source
since oxidation is occurring at the
inert electrode on the left this
electrode must be the anode
as a quick review remember that a good
way to remember this is to think about
an ox and a cat so oxidation occurs at
the anode that's an ox and reduction
occurs at the cathode that's a red cat
and as a quick summary this diagram
shows the electrolytic cell for the
electrolysis of molten sodium chloride
to form liquid sodium and chlorine gas
let's look at another example of an
electrolytic cell
this electrolytic cell shows the process
of electroplating so let's say you have
a pendant made of steel and you do some
engraving on it i do a lot of engraving
and so i drew a little picture of some
flowers on this steel pendant however
steel rusts pretty easily so if we want
to protect the engraving we could
electroplate it and put a thin layer of
nickel on top of the steel so
electroplating uses electrolysis to
plate one metal onto another metal
either to protect against rust or
corrosion or if you want to plate silver
or gold onto another metal to make it
more beautiful so for this electrolytic
cell we have a steel electrode on the
right and a nickel electrode on the left
and we have an aqueous solution of
nickel sulfate we know that electrons
come from the negative terminal of the
power source so imagine that electrons
move in the wire toward the steel
electrode on the right
when the nickel two plus ions in
solution come in contact with the
electrons at the surface of the steel
electrode reduction takes place
so reduction takes place at the cathode
and for the half reaction it'd be nickel
two plus plus two electrons turns into
solid nickel so a thin layer of nickel
is now plated on the steel object the
electrode on the left is a piece of
solid nickel and when solid nickel is
oxidized it turns into nickel two plus
ions when solid nickel turns into nickel
two plus ions in solution two electrons
are lost and so we can think about
electrons moving in this wire back
toward the positive terminal of the
power source
so for the oxidation half reaction solid
nickel turns into nickel two plus ions
and two electrons are lost and because
oxidation occurs at the anode the nickel
electrode is the anode for this
electrolytic cell let's look at a quick
summary for an electrolytic cell in an
electrolytic cell the redox reaction is
thermodynamically unfavorable
because the redox reaction is
thermodynamically unfavorable an
electrolytic cell requires a power
source to supply a current to drive the
unfavorable redox reaction oxidation
occurs at the anode and reduction occurs
at the cathode
and finally an electrolytic cell is used
for electroplating where a thin layer of
one metal is plated onto another metal